[Music]
hey Jenny
well that's some strong for lung
iContact so we're gonna bounce
they were together nine years I thought
we could handle anything and so I
actually just got a drop in San
Francisco I just don't feel like I'm
ready to leave New York
[Music]
we're before-and-after pictures right
now well I gotta kill you okay basically
I just really want you to call your
place of work and tell them you have
your period or something and then just
come over my apartment you know the
beginning of a disaster movie like right
before the girl who looks like me dies
and like right when a girl who look like
you walked outside and be like oh my God
look how crazy this guy looks this feels
like that I leave in a week and then I
turn 30 and then I die probably I need
one last epic day with my crush
[Music]
but you holding me back
I am deeply obsessed with us right now I
can't leave never say like this is the
end of an era everything's changing I
mean we're out here taking R if you have
a girlfriend
whatever kindly leave your
heteronormative labels and a
[__] box thank you making
choices you still have that boyfriend
you hate oh oh I'm sorry I was just
goofing around
yes this just can't be where it ends
this is destiny you are Beyonce
I love you guys for real
our best friend is out there drinking
champagne from a bottle of green juice I
just want to scoop her up and make it
all go away wait is the green juice
mimosa sky Jenny's I feel better I'm
gonna pick up
you